now you may have noticed that I'm
looking a little different to how I did
yesterday those of you who've guessed
I'm now wearing an orange jacket and
I've got a camera attached to my head
you'd be right thanks to my favorite
cameraman Dan you're now going to be
able to experience the conference from
the inside get ready let's go on a
stupendous adventure this is the
registration area hello could I register
please my name is malenka so I wouldn't
be able to carry it but you're very kind
to offer thank you so much all the best
now i would put this on but i think i
have a bit of a headpiece on me at the
moment this is where we get beeped in
thank you very much here we are in the
excel exhibition center note that
everyone's looking at me in a funny way
i do i'm gonna take you in to the dome
okay now this is where all of your
technological dreams come true hi my
name is malenka what's your name
Christo's nice to meet you we're on our
way to the three-dimensional printer
here we go there's a two dimensional
printing which is made let me show you
some other examples decision that's just
a few this is now the ftth
fiber-to-the-home actually you're
scanning this 360 degrees you file it
and you print it now while there's a
fiber come in for this file is much
heavier you need fiber network which no
matter how heavy the file is we will
still go very fast to it sure print or
web and supplier and you can print it
for you Wow imagine you have left home
this morning you told your children
we're going to school after after you
leave don't forget the lights no mom
don't forget the heating no mom you come
back home the evening lights on heating
full take do that well you can do is now
take leave home check this already
existed emoticons system you check on
your on your smart phone or your iPad
whatever oh they forgot it just put out
of Switzerland let's try to example this
is for example
let's put on like if I got it on okay
it's on I put it on okay but the problem
today is if you have to connect you
happen sometimes you're on the phone
either it's as simple and you lose
contact even though we have now a
wireless connection the fiber will allow
us to have a certainty of contact now we
did close the door we did out switch off
the light just as this gentleman's done
I'm going to have some of their Smarties
I want 50 mm little bit a drink a little
bit of sep power that's what everybody
needs a little bit of here it's carry on
because I'm gonna go and get a coffee
okay hi there could i possibly get a
decaf coffee thanks very much caffeine
and me don't mix well together Oh a
cookie no I just ate some fiber but I
couldn't resist thank you so much let's
go to the plenary where there might be
some seriously hot stuff happening to be
quite something once we get in here so
stay with me okay now this time
yesterday there were 3,000 people in
this room careful done
let's go and sit at the back so I'm
going to sit down here now and I think
because there's something that's most
likely very top secret that's being
talked about at the moment I'm gonna sit
down and shut off the camera see you
soon